huyen del techo al que los trasladó el
invasor en sus maletas cargan
pertenencias y parte de lo vivido en su
país de origen y es que con la llegada
de las tropas rusas muchos ucranianos
fueron reubicados en ocasiones a la
fuerza y sin saber el destino que en
muchos casos sería territorio enemigo
había gente con armas 5 de ellos me
rodearon y me dijeron tú no eliges irán
donde te carguen a lo que respondí lo
siento no somos ganados somos personas y
tenemos derecho a saber a dónde nos
llevan
ya en rusia su principal objetivo es
huir grupos como éste llegan todos los
días para cruzar el puente que los lleva
hacia estonia una red secreta de
voluntarios rusos nos ayuda a escapar
pero la salida no es fácil
cuando sales de rusia una vez más tienes
que pasar por un proceso como de
filtración te preguntas si conoces algún
miembro del ejército ucraniano y qué
piensas sobre la llamada 'operación
especial y toman tus huellas dactilares
medios de prensa destacan que según
funcionarios de las partes en conflicto
unos dos millones de refugiados
ucranianos terminaron en rusia moscú la
llamada evacuaciones humanitarias
kiev las califica como deportaciones
forzadas considerado como un crimen de
guerra